if you can't pay attention you can't
achieve your goals i want to read this
book or a bigger goal i want to write a
book i want to set up a business i want
to be a good dad whatever it might be
whatever your goals are if you lose your
ability to pay attention you cannot
achieve those goals that's true at a
personal level and that's true at the
level of a whole society right a society
of people who are adored and can't pay
attention won't be able to achieve
collective goals either
johan hari welcome to the show hey chris
good to be with you really glad to have
you back man i'm very excited hooray yes
precisely so you say
that each book that you write is trying
to solve or work out a different mystery
why did you get interested in the
mystery of attention
oh god you know for so many years i felt
my own attention getting worse
i looked at so many of the people i knew
and i could see their attention was
getting worse
but i was responding to that by saying
really by blaming myself like everyone
else only was blaming themselves and
thinking oh you know you're just weak
you're not strong enough you don't have
enough willpower
um
and then i i was
i also reassured myself by saying well
every generation feels like this right
you can read letters from monks almost a
thousand years ago where one of them
writes to the other one
and says oh my attention ain't what it
used to be right it's not exact quote
but that's the gist of what they said
and i thought okay so this is just you
know you get older your attention gets
worse
but really it was looking at the young
people in my life
and some young people i love
that made me think you know what this
really does feel markedly different and
then i started looking at some of the
studies of this there's a small study
for example of american college students
that found that on average they focus on
any one task for 65 seconds
and the average office worker focuses on
any one task for three minutes
i thought
there's something deeper going on here
so i ended up going on this huge journey
all over the world fortunately
pre-plague uh i interviewed over 200 of
the leading experts in the world about
focus what causes it to boost what
causes it to deteriorate i went from
miami to moscow to melbourne um
and i went to places that have been
affected by this attention crisis in all
sorts of different ways from a favela in
rio de janeiro where attention had
collapsed in a particularly disastrous
way to an office in new zealand where
they found an incredible way to boost
attention and
and what i concluded
having met the kind of leading experts
in the world
is there's actually scientific evidence
for 12 factors that can boost or
or degrade your attention
loads of those factors have been really
significantly increasing in recent times
and we are in a real and acute attention
crisis which is actually on course to
get even worse
unless we deal with these deep
underlying causes of the crisis
so it is a modern phenomenon
i i'd say it's the result of very
specific things that are happening in
the modern world it's not just the
modern world in itself we could have
the benefits of the modern world without
most of this if we make the necessary
adjustments but it's definitely
this to some degree there's you know
this is a perennial human dilemma but
it's gotten much worse in response to
specific things that are happening now
what was the trip that you took where
you
sequestered yourself before the plague
you decided to take yourself away with a
special needs big big button phone and
um
and throw yourself on an island what
happened there well it was a response to
something else that happened actually
and that was really the reason why i
wrote the book so when when he was nine
years old my godson
developed this brief obsession with
elvis i never understood how he found
out about elvis but um he would start
like obsessively singing viva las vegas
and suspicious minds and it was
particularly cute because he didn't know
that had become like a cheesy cliche so
he was doing it with his heart catching
sincerity
and he kept getting me to tell him the
story of elvis's life and obviously i
tried to skip over the bit where elvis
you know shits himself to death on the
toilet um but one night when i was
tucking him in
he said to me very intensely said joham
will you take me one day to graceland
and i said yeah sure in the way that you
tell nine-year-olds to do something no
they'll forget it the next day and he
said no do you really promise you'll
take me to graceland and i was like yes
i absolutely promise
and i didn't think of it again until 10
years later when so many things have
gone wrong
so when he was 15 he dropped out of
school
and by the time he was 19 he was
just
constantly alternating between his ipad
his laptop and his iphone and his life
was just a blur of whatsapp youtube porn
and and one day we were sitting you
can't see it but the sofa just behind
the laptop where we're talking we were
sitting there
and i was trying to talk to him and it
was like he was whirring at the speed of
snapchat it was like nothing still or
serious could touch him and it was
really distressing and it was
distressing partly because i could feel
the same
thing happening to me it wasn't as
extreme but i could feel this thing i
was sitting there looking at my own
phone and i suddenly remembered this
moment from all those years before
and i said to him hey let's go to
graceland and he was like what i didn't
even remember this thing that happened
and so i reminded him and i said look
i'll take to graceland we've got to
break this numbing routine but when we
go there you've got to leave your phone
in the hotel while we're away you can't
just be taking it everywhere and he said
i promise i'll do that
so we two weeks later we flew from uh
heathrow to new orleans which is where
we went first anyway a couple of weeks
later we arrived at graceland and when
you arrive at graceland even pre-covered
there's no person to show you around
what happens is they they give you an
ipad and you put in earbuds and the ipad
shows you around so it says go left go
right and every room you're in it tells
you about that room and there's in every
room there's a digital representation of
that room on the ipad
so we're walking around graceland and
i'm noticing that what happens is
everyone just walks around graceland
staring at the ipad i'm getting more and
more tense
and we got to the jungle room which was
elvis favorite room in graceland it's
kind of loads of fake plants
and there's this canadian couple next to
us
and the husband turned to the wife and
he said honey this is amazing look
if you swipe left you can see the jungle
room to the left
and if you swipe right you can see the
jungle room to the right
and i thought he was joking so i looked
up and laughed and then him and his wife
just started swiping back and forward
and and i turned to him and i said but
sir
there's an old-fashioned form of swiping
you can do
it's called turning your head because
look we're actually in the jungle room
right you don't have to look at a
digital representation we're literally
there and they clearly thought i was
insane i'm sort of backed away
understandably and i turned to my godson
to laugh about it and he was just
standing in the corner looking at
snapchat because from the minute we
landed
he
was just
constantly looking at it he couldn't
keep his promise and i just lost it i
shouted at him and i said you know
you're afraid of missing out but this is
guaranteeing that you'll miss out you're
not being present at your own life i
tried to grab his phone off him and he
sort of stomped off
and i wandered around graceland on my
own and then that night i found him in
the heartbreak hotel down the street
where we were staying where there's a
swimming pool shaped like a guitar
and he was sitting by the swimming pool
and and he was looking at his phone and
i apologized to him and he said look i
know something is really wrong but i
don't know what it is
and that's when i thought oh [ __ ] i need
to look into this
and at first i thought well this is a
personal purely personal problem right
he can't stop looking i can't stop
looking the solution is to do something
personal i thought the problem lay in me
and in my phone
so i did this very drastic thing i just
i i booked a little place in a beach
house in provincetown in cape cod
and i s and i said to everyone i knew
look i'm going completely offline for
three months i'm gonna have a phone that
can't access the internet i'm gonna have
a laptop my friend mtas gave me his old
broken laptop that couldn't get online
um i'm just i'm just tired of being
wired in this way i'm i'm i'm out of it
right and so i went to provincetown for
three months with no phone and it was
this kind of
it taught me a lot um
both about the strengths of that
approach and the weaknesses of it and
what were they
well the first few weeks were like a
haze of decompression
and this
incredible sense of relief and it's a
very funny place provincetown for people
who don't know it it's a little kind of
gay resort town it's a place where more
than one person makes a full-time living
dressing as ursula the villain from the
little mermaid and singing songs about
cunnilingus so it gives you some sense
of what it's like something that sort of
haze of decompression
thinking oh this is this is
this is so good thank god it was like
and then about two weeks in i had this
really bitter crash i was
walking down the beach and provincetown
like grey stand like every place you'll
ever go now
was just full of people who were using
prototypes one of the most beautiful
places in the world
we're just using provincetown as a
backdrop for their selfies so you're
seeing these people it's particularly
painful to see what parents with
children doing this
who were just never looking around them
who were just constantly looking at
their phones
but instead of thinking oh you don't
know how to be present i start thinking
give me that phone i [ __ ] want it
right and i felt this tremendous craving
and i
and i realized that for
so many years
you know i had been exposed throughout
the day to the kind of thin insistent
signals of the internet of the web of
the current apps that we use
um
and when those were gone this is a very
pretentious way of saying it but simone
de beauvoir the french philosopher said
that
when she became an atheist it was like
the world had gone silent and that's how
it felt it felt like the world had gone
silent like i
like the crucial signals that i needed
were gone and even if you're getting on
well with people and i was getting well
with people in providence town
they're not
you know
people don't flood you with hearts the
minute they meet you right um
so so i realized after that
actually i i had created a vacuum where
previously the signals of the internet
were
and it wasn't enough to just separate my
it's necessary it was necessary for a
period to separate myself from that but
then what i needed to do was fill that
vacuum with something and i started to
learn a lot i had already learned a lot
and i started to read more and later met
the leading scientist who learned about
flow states which i can talk about in a
minute um
but i was amazed that once i
once i got through that the haze of
decompression and then the dip
what amazed me
was how much my attention came back i
thought you know i'm 42 i thought
i thought well surely my brain is
terrorists a bit you know actually my
attention was as good as it was when i
was 17. i was lying there reading books
for like eight hours not feeling not my
attention not atrophying
um and i remember towards the end of
those three months
thinking this is amazing i never want to
go back to that
to that way of being
um
and then within a couple of weeks of
getting back to boston and getting my
phone back
my attention was as bad as it ever been
and i had to really explore okay well
what's happening here why is it so hard
to sustain those lessons in our normal
lives
and how can we begin to do it
the interesting thing you say about your
godson and that sort of frenetic
very
sort of um anxious bouncy attention that
he had i read a
i want to say it was a washington post
huge op-ed piece from a psychology high
school teacher
or university teacher that went to go
and live with some of the most famous
tick tockers in a clout house oh
fascinating so he goes and lives with
them and he tells this story about how
they
one of the evenings they were going to
go and play basketball and they were
saying right let's go and play a game of
basketball let's organize it and it's
all everything's a bit kind of hyper and
it's like everyone's on e numbers and
too much caffeine anyway um but these
people have ridiculous numbers of
followers you know some of the most
followed tick-tock accounts on the
planet and then they spend time
organizing people into groups and
picking who the teams are going to be
and then just as they're about to play
the game
someone
walks off the
pitch walks off the basketball court and
then slowly everybody else walks off as
well and he turns to one of the guys and
he says hang on you guys just made all
of this time picking teams and saying
that we're going to play a game of
basketball and now one person's walked
off and a bunch of other people have
walked off and now it's not going to
happen he says oh yeah this happens all
the time
people just start something and then
they can't even hold their attention on
the thing that they just began to do and
they get distracted and walk off and
there's something
we all experience the degradation of our
attention inside of our brains right
but what i find
so
strange is when it manifests physically
you know when you see someone locomote
themselves from one location to another
because they simply couldn't hold on to
i'm supposed to be doing this physical
thing it feels like when it manifests
physically it feels like another degree
of uh like insanity
i love that story because it's like a
parable
about what i think is the worst aspect
of this attention crisis which it which
has two levels
and so if you can't pay attention you
can't achieve your goals about anything
right so a personal level anything you
want to achieve from a small thing i
want to go to the shop and buy
some diet coke or a bigger thing i want
to read this book or a bigger goal i
want to write a book i want to set up a
business i want to be a good dad
whatever it might be
whatever your goals are if you lose your
ability to pay attention you cannot
achieve those goals that's true at a
personal level and that's true at the
level of a whole society right a society
of people who are adored and can't pay
attention won't be able to achieve
collective goals either so
i think you're absolutely right that
that's the chilling thing
and and you're also right when it
manifests physically it's more
disturbing because of the 12 causes that
i learned about a lot of them are in
relation to the body
um which surprised me
um the
sleep you know we we sleep 20 less than
we did 100 years ago that is a physical
process we desperately physically need
and even if that was the only thing that
had changed dr charles seisler the
leading expert in the world on sleep are
the medical schools said to me even if
nothing else to change that alone would
be causing a huge crisis and attention
children sleep 80 minutes less than they
did 100 years ago that that alone would
be causing a huge crisis in children's
attention there's loads of evidence that
the way we eat um
the the kind of standard western diet
has a catastrophic effect on people's
ability to focus and pay attention
there's a whole range of these which are
physical body i mean the fact that we
are the first human society ever in the
last 100 years
who think it is either possible or
sensible to get small children to sit
still for eight hours a day
when all the scientific evidence shows
children's attention grows when they can
run around and exercise so you see again
these may seem like no [ __ ] sherlock
insights but we don't live in in in
we're not acting on these insights we
have a society that's radically
disconnected from these insights so you
i think there's so many things in that
parable that you've just said about the
parable of the tick tockers that um
yeah i love that
how have you come to
understand how attention works then
after all of this research how do you
frame like what attention is and and how
it works
so so many ways of thinking about it and
and i was surprised by how complex of
phenomena and attention is and it re
it's a physical process like we just
said requiring all these things if you
disturb yourself physically to use one
example by eating foods that cause
energy spikes and energy crashes which i
do uh that's going to [ __ ] your
attention there's so there's a physical
process
there's many layers of attention there's
a wonderful guy who really helped me to
think about this
called dr james williams who was a
google designer for many years very
senior at google became profoundly
disenchanted with what they were doing
to the world's intention attention
quit and is now i think the most
important philosopher of attention in
the world i interviewed him in moscow he
was living there because his wife works
with the world health organization
and
james has created this kind of a
typology of attention i think is really
helpful he says there are three layers
of attention i would actually suggest a
fourth as well which i think he would
agree i know he would agree with so the
first level of attention
is what we call the spotlight right this
is this is the dominant way we think
about attention so
your spotlight is so i'm in a room now
where in the corner over there there's
my television my phone is somewhere in
this room i've hidden it so i don't
can't see it while i'm talking to you um
there's noise in this room you know i
can see people out my window but i have
i've
filtering all of that out and i'm
narrowing my spotlight onto you right
and i'm looking at your face and
thinking what did chris just ask me so
the spotlight
is your ability to attend to immediate
short-term tasks by filtering out all
the [ __ ] around you right um and we all
know how that works that's actually
generally most of the debate about
attention when we think oh i can't pay
attention we think of being distracted
in that sense right i sat there to read
a book but my phone rang i was trying to
spend time with my kids but you know
but my boss emailed me so we think about
that immediate form of disruption of
spotlight so dr williams suggests
there's a a second layer which is what
he calls your starlight
and your starlight is your medium to
long-term goals right so it's not i want
to you know read this book or answer
this email it's i want to set up a
business i want to be a good dad i want
to write a book it's your medium to
long-term goals and the third car it's
called the starlight because when you're
lost in the desert
uh you look to the stars and you figure
out where you're going right
the third layer is what he calls your
daylight
and your daylight is how you even know
what your long-term goals are
how do you know
that you want to
set up a business how do you know what
kind of business you want to set up how
do you know you want to write a book how
do you know what it means to be a good
parent right
to have it's called daylight because you
can only see clearly when the room is
flooded with daylight right
how
how do you know these things
if you are constant if your life is
dissolved into 65 second and
three-minute pellets like a hailstorm is
constantly going on around your
attention how do you know who you are if
you never get time to think and
contemplate away from being constantly
disrupted
and and and [ __ ] with right
and and he argues that we're not just
being disrupted at the level of the
spotlight which is what we think about
but our ability to achieve longer term
goals is being profoundly disrupted and
our ability to even know what our longer
term goals should be
is being profoundly disruptive i would
argue there's a fourth layer which i
would call our stadium lights which is
how we see each other as a society how
can we achieve sustained goals right
there's all sorts of crises facing our
society
but if if if we can't focus it's not
just that you can't achieve your goals
we together can't achieve our goals it
[ __ ] us at every level so i think at
the moment
all four of those forms of attention are
being
profoundly disrupted for us and for our
children but we
the reason i'm most optimistic about
this is because that i think there are
ways back from this the problem is that
there's a trickle-down effect right that
if you fracture and fragment the
spotlight that means that you don't ever
make progress towards your meaningful
long-term goals and as you start to do
that the cohesive narrative that you
make around who am i what are my values
why am i here that begins to get
fractured and fragmented so much and
then over time as you spread that out
across a bunch of individuals that
cohese together to make themselves into
a society they don't get to do it
there's a line in uh it's either digital
minimalism or deep work
where cal newport says
he's talking about twitter specifically
and he says twitter fractures our days
into slivers so small that we can't get
anything meaningful done because we're
just constantly task switching from one
form to another and we'll get onto task
switching in fact that's let's talk
about that what's the issue with
speed and switching and filtering
yeah there's this is one of the first
interviews i did for the book and it was
so big actually
almost the very first interview i did
with the book really [ __ ] sobered me
i just before i get to switching you
just made me think of it there's a guy
called professor roy baumeister he's a
professor at the university of
queensland he's a legend one of the most
distinguished psychologists ever but
people who've heard of the marshmallow
test he's the guy who invented the
marshmallow test so he's the lead by far
the leading expert in the world on
willpower
he wrote a book called willpower right
so go and interview him and i say oh you
know professor about my strong think of
writing a book about whether people are
struggling to pay attention and he said
do you know
there's no exact words there in the book
he said you know it's interesting you
say that because i've just found i can't
really pay attention a lot of the time
now i just play video games on my phone
all the time but i'm sort of saying that
i'm like
wait didn't you write a book called
willpower this is the godfather of
willpower and he's struggling i was like
[ __ ] me if you can't pay attention
this is really happening to everyone
so it was really so i remember walking
that interview i got there to be feeling
a bit dazed right i was like it's like
you go to yoda and yoda just goes i
don't know right yeah i'm just playing
clash of clan clash of clans over here
on my phone and sorry it was really
dispiriting but then one of the moments
it started to fall into place for me so
this this cause that you're talking
about um i went to interview a guy
called dr professor earl miller who's
one of the leading neuroscientists in
the world he's at mit the massachusetts
institute of technology and professor
miller said to me
you've got to understand one thing about
the human brain more than anything else
you can only think
about one thing at a time
that's it consciously right that's it
this is a fundamental
aspect of the structure of the human
brain the human brain
has not changed significantly in 40 000
years
it ain't going to change on any
timetable any of us are going to see um
you can only think about one thing at a
time
but he said we have fallen
for a mass delusion the average teenager
now believes they can follow seven forms
of media at the same time but what
happens is when professor miller's uh
colleagues get people into labs and they
test them they say okay they get them to
do a lot think they're doing lots of
things at the same time what they always
discover is that in fact when you think
you're doing more than one thing at a
time you're juggling you're very quickly
alternating between tasks right your
consciousness papers over it it gives a
seamless impression that you're just
doing one thing
but actually
you're juggling and this comes with a
really significant cost it's called the
switch cost effect and it turns out when
you are juggling it degrades profoundly
degrades your ability to do any of the
things you're doing
and there's lots of forms of harm we can
talk about but i'll just look at there's
two studies i think that really two
small studies that help me to think
about this
hewlett packard the printer company
uh commissioned a scientist to do a
study where they got a group of their
workers and they split them into two
groups first group was told just do
whatever your task is for for the day
and we won't interrupt you second group
was told do your task for the day and
you're going to have to respond to a lot
of emails and phone calls
and then they tested the iq of both
groups
the group who was not distracted not
interrupted
scored 10 iq points higher than the
group that was to give you a sense of
how big that is if you or me smoked a
fat spliff now together and got stoned
our iqs would go down by five points
so just being chronically interrupted
had twice as bad an effect on your iq as
getting stoned you would be better off
in the short term there's debate about
the longer term effect of cannabis on iq
but in the short term you'll be better
off sitting at your desk getting stoned
and doing one thing at a time than
sitting at your desk not getting stoned
and being bombarded
with emails and phone calls
just to quickly say another study the
carnegie mellon human computer
interaction lab did a really interesting
study they got 138 students they split
them into two groups they got them all
of them to do the same exam but one
group
was told just do it in normal exam
conditions and the other group was told
um you can you can have your phone on
and you can send and receive texts now
instinctively you would expect the
second group to do better because they
could have cheated right in fact the
second group on average did 20 worse
because being interrupted
ruins your ability to think
professor michael posner at the
university of oregon found that if you
are interrupted it takes you on average
23 minutes to get back to the same level
of focus you had before but most people
never get 23 minutes of uninterrupted
time at work right you said that it was
on average three minutes and 30 seconds
for people that are in a workplace
environment or 65 seconds for a uni
student
and this goes right to the top the
average ceo of fortune 500 company only
gets 26 uninterrupted minutes a day
right so at every level of the economy
every level of the society
well the way professor miller put it to
me is we're living in a perfect storm of
cognitive degradation as a result of
this constant interruption
and again i remember leaving that
interview
feeling pretty [ __ ] sobered thinking
it's one thing to have this suspicion of
something's happening here but when you
go and you keep interviewing like the
leading scientists in the world on these
questions and they're saying no this is
really bad right i i remember
interviewing
professor barbara domini who's one of
the leading scientists in france
but she won the legend which is the
biggest civilian award you can get in
france
um
and her just saying well there's no way
you can have a normal brain today and
thinking
[ __ ] this is you know but so that can
feel when you hear it and was to me when
i first learned it very overwhelming but
the reason why i feel
uh why i think there's reason to be
optimistic is because there are
solutions to these problems and i think
they have to happen at two levels so one
level is the personal there are personal
solutions we can pursue in our as
isolated individuals in our own lives
and we can talk about lots of them i'll
just give you one example you can't see
it from here chris but in the corner of
the room over there i've got it's called
a k-safe this company should start
[ __ ] paying me commission because i'm
saying this in every podcast but they're
not sadly uh so k-safe is a plastic safe
you
take the lid off you put your phone in
you put the lid on you turn the dial at
the top and it will shut your phone away
for anything between five minutes and
a week
and you lock it and you can't get your
phone i mean if there was a fire or
something you could just smash it but
then you'd have to buy another casing um
so i do i use that for four hours a day
i would not have been able to write my
books if i didn't do that also on the
laptop i'm speaking to you on i have an
app called freedom which can cut you off
either from the specific websites you
tell it to if you were addicted to say
twitter or just the entire internet and
i use that for the same four hours
um every day so there's lots of personal
things we can all do in our lives to
defend ourselves and our children
against the systematic invasion of our
of our attention
but i want to be honest with people
the evidence shows that that can improve
your attention but it will only get you
so far because at the moment
it's like we're living in an environment
where someone is and by the way tech is
of the 12 causes not the biggest which
surprised me
and
we are living in an environment that is
constantly
pouring itching powder on us and it's a
bit like at the moment the person
pouring itching powder on us is going
you know what mate um you might want to
learn how to meditate then you wouldn't
scratch so much
and
yeah i'm in favor of meditation but [ __ ]
you we need to stop you pouring itching
powder on us right
um so we've got to have another level of
response
at which together we are taking on these
forces that are [ __ ] with our ability
to pay attention i know that can sound a
bit abstract so can i give very quickly
a specific example of a place that did
that
so
france in 2018 was having a big crisis
of what they called le burnout which i
don't think i need to translate and the
french government under pressure from
the trade unions
uh got a guy called bruno mettling who
was the head of orange one of their
biggest telecoms companies to
figure out what the [ __ ] was going on
and he found he did loads of research
and he discovered that 35 of french
people felt they could never turn off
their phones or stop checking their
emails when they were awake because
their boss could message them at any
time of the day or night and if they
didn't reply you know they were in
trouble
so you can give those people all the
sweet self-help lectures you want in the
world about oh you'd be much better off
buy a case say they can't do it right i
remember thinking when i learned that
figure
you know when you're younger than me
chris but i remember when
when i was a kid the only people who
were on call
were the prime minister and doctors and
even doctors weren't on call all the
time right now 35 of the economy is just
on call all the time and many people are
burdened by this many more people are
burdened by this
um so bruno mettling proposed a very
simple solution which the french
government then introduced into law it's
called the right to disconnect it just
says two things you have a legal right
to have your work hours defined in your
contract and you have a legal right to
not have to check your phone or email
outside those work hours
that's it so i went to paris to
interview people about this uh just
before i was there rent a kill the pest
control company got fined 70 000 euros
because they tried to get one of their
workers they told off one of their
workers for not responding to an email
an hour after his work hours ended now
you can see how that's a collective
thing companies are never going to do
that unless we make them do it i mean
some might do it as a benefit but that's
yeah they're getting a few benevolent
bosses but most are not that's something
where you can't do that on your own you
can go to your boss and say i want a
right to disconnect and they'll go like
[ __ ] off right but we can do that
collectively by banding together and
fighting for that to be introduced so
that's one of many things we need to do
collectively so we've got to all these
problems have to be tackled at both
levels the individual things we can do
which will get us to a certain level and
then the collective things we can do
which will make it possible for many
more of us to do those individual things
does that ring true to you chris
yeah it does so we had this discussion
when we talked about lost connections
your last book on depression and i think
that this um
belies a like a bias that i have where
such i'm an only child right so radical
personal responsibility and never ever
looking to anything else outside of me
for a solution it always surprises me
when you uh talk about how sort of
systemic changes can influence the
individual because that that's a
solution that doesn't often come very
true to me one of the things that
i'm not that i'm concerned about but one
of the things that i think
it would need to be and you put it
across well in the book it needs to be
laid at people's feet like look you need
to do everything that you can personally
to be able to try and sort your
attention out and then we can band
together to try and make these changes
occur long term because they're not
going to happen straight away one of the
concerns that i would have is that it's
potentially easy for people to fall into
a victim mentality well look johan's
book said look at this environment that
i'm living in i'm being forced there's
itching powder being poured on me look i
can never get out of of this sub-optimal
attentional environment right um and i
think that it's important that people
realize yes there are challenges that
you have in the environment you need to
do the things that you can and over time
we can try and make the environment
become better and i think that the blend
between the two is correct but it always
surprises me
how many uh solutions are actually out
there that can be done that are going to
assist people with what they can do
personally because almost all of the
solutions that i look to immediately are
right well i'll i'll try and fix it i'll
try and come up with some sort of a
solution but
i mean to try and run through some of
the ridiculous ways that i sort my
attention out i sleep with my phone
outside of my bedroom i have two
separate phones one has social media on
and the other one is for for messaging
the one that has social media on has no
sim card so that one's always attached
to the wi-fi in my house i have
intermittent fasting for my phone i
don't use it before a certain time i
don't use it after a certain time i have
an app called cold turkey on my laptop
which locks me out of my laptop after a
particular time at night and i can't get
out of that there's a option on that
called frozen turkey which literally
just shuts your laptop down and there's
nothing that you can do to stop it now
i've
gone away on a holiday and not enabled
data roaming so that i don't ever use my
phone as soon as i leave the apartment
like just pick your endless number the
notifications have been turned off go on
grayscale mode on the phone and
there's an awful lot of tricks and and
tips and stuff that i've put together to
try and constrain how much my attention
can be distracted
and yet for the fact that i didn't
realize maybe there is something
systemic out there i i think it was
almost like you know what it was it was
almost like learned helplessness
i think it was almost like i don't think
that we can enact change these big tech
companies are going to be so powerful
and they have so much influence and they
make so much money there is no way that
we're going to be able to actually do
anything to impact them so
it's all on me like i'll carry the boat
david goggins style right and i think
that that was kind of
that was where i got to and um
yeah it you know i really do hope that
we can try and make a better attentional
environment because it worries me
how
nerfed the
human species growth has been
due to the fact that in the space of 10
years 10 years ago around about 2011
2012 i think we had the optimal amount
of information available on the internet
briefly for a two-month period in like
the autumn of 2011 or something we had
the right amount of information
available and then very quickly we went
from a world where information was a
scarcity that you wanted to get more of
because it would help you survive it
would make you more competitive it would
make you more attractive it would mean
that you had better life
very quickly went from wanting more to
needing to filter less
the best people on the planet the
smartest people on the planet now are
not the ones that can forage for
information they're the ones that can
sort signal from noise they're the ones
that can discriminate between what they
don't need in the wealth of information
that's hitting them in the face and what
they do need and that skill is just not
one that we've got i'm sure that you've
heard about information foraging that
that's i think it's the same
neuroscientist that you spoke to earlier
on that talks about that the fact that
we're constantly on the lookout for
information because it was so scarce and
so important and so useful to us in our
past and um yeah man some systemic
changes would also be pretty nice
well it's about i love what you just
said i think that's so interesting i
just want to think through a few of the
things you've said chris because
um i'm just processing them and i think
what you're saying is it is really
important because
i had a similar sort of dialogue with
myself
um where
so i was going into being i'll give you
an example a guy called professor joel
nigg who is the um
leading expert on children's detention
problems in the us
and um
he said to me that that we're living in
what he call he thinks we might be now
living in what he calls an attentional
pathogenic environment
which is where for everyone forms of
deep focus like reading a book are
getting more and more like running up a
down escalator
and
um
one of the worries about that
is that it's not like we will even
remain at the current level of
invasiveness of our attention
many of the factors invading our
attention are going to get much worse
paul graham one of the leading silicon
valley
um unbelievable
yeah yeah and a hugely prominent figure
in silicon valley said that
the world is on course to be more
addictive in the next 40 years compared
to the last 40 years
um if we don't regulate the way this
stuff works that's me adding the clause
if we don't regulate not him um
so
i thought a lot about this because
when you hear that
initially it can feel
exactly what you said the last thing i
ever want to do with anyone in my
writing about addiction depression or
um
or attention
is to inculcate a victim mentality
if people read my book and thought well
i'm [ __ ] then then i have failed
completely because you're genuinely not
[ __ ] and i think part of the problem
is
how did i put this
that people feel like it's about it's
about the question is about asking
people where your power lies right
so if you think about
people feel like
understand very understandably feel like
i have power over my immediate behavior
to some degree
but if something is bigger than me i
have no power over that right and a big
part of what i want to communicate to
people because
i think the evidence is very clear that
it's true
is that you have power at many levels
now you have power at the level of your
individual behavior
and even people in the most horrendous
environment if you are in solitary
confinement for the rest of your life
you still have some power over what you
do right a viktor frankl wrote about how
he exercised agency in the concentration
camps you when he was in prison there by
the nazis and his family were murdered
you always have some agency
um but also at the individual level but
you also have power a collective level
when you band together with other people
and i want to just give a very practical
example and i would really urge people
to think about their own families in
relation to this as well
[Music]
i think a lot about my grandmother's
part like i was raised by my scottish
grandmother because my mother was ill
when i was a kid and my dad was in a
different country
so my grandmothers
i'm 42 my grandmothers were 42 in 1963.
one of my grandmothers was a working
class scottish woman living in a
scottish tenement and my other
grandmother was living in a wooden heart
on the side of a mountain in switzerland
and in 1963
neither of them was allowed to have a
bank account because they were married
women
neither of them
was allowed well both of them could be
legally raped by their husbands
um in practice their husbands could beat
the [ __ ] out of them because the police
never did anything about domestic
violence my swiss grandmother wasn't
even allowed to vote
and
both of them had left school when they
were 13 even though the men in their
families carried on going to school
later because no one gave a [ __ ] about
girls being able to learn anything
my swiss grandmother she loved to paint
and draw but they were like [ __ ] why
are you doing that [ __ ] shut up get
into the kitchen
um so i think about their lives right
when they were they were the age i am
now i knew them 60 years ago yeah this
is very recently right
and then i look at my niece who's 17
who loves to draw and paint she never
knew my grandmother sadly
um loves to draw and paint
and
when she draws and paints we're like
you should go to art school this is
brilliant right
um
and
even
like no one you would be regarded as a
deranged maniac if you said
my niece should not be allowed to have a
bank account it should be legal for her
to be raped you know she shouldn't be
allowed to vote i mean it'd be
unthinkable right no one would ever
literally no one says that right or
perhaps the craziest farthest fringe but
like almost nobody
um
how did that change happen right
at the level of my grandmother's in 1963
i can well imagine them saying
[ __ ] me we're never gonna take this on
right how is this ever going to change
in 1963
every single country company police
force
all of them were controlled by men and
had been ever since those things were
invented thousands of years before right
except for a few hereditary queens every
now and then right um
at the level of the isolated individual
you could say to my grandmother look you
have some agency yeah i mean she could
have
there were certain things adjustments
they could make in their behavior but
the truth is that
the margin for them to make changes in
that society were very limited so how
did we get to the change where my niece
does have lots of margins my niece just
she was going out with a boy he didn't
treat her well she told her to [ __ ] off
all the boys around sided with her a
complete transformation it was
unthinkable to my grandmothers right um
how how did we get that it didn't happen
because lots of women made isolated
individual changes it happened because
lots of women banded together and plenty
of sympathetic men as well and said
we're not going to [ __ ] take this
anymore right no
uh
and i would argue
um so i think that's really important
about people knowing where their power
lies
i stress
very strongly and i know this is your
instinct as well we we have power as
isolated individuals but we also have
power we band together and in a way i i
don't think of those things
you can overdo the separation between
those things right so you can think
there's there's i have power or the
collective has power but the collective
is you it's you banding together with
everyone else that's how changes happen
and we're all the beneficiaries of those
changes right
think about something as that we used to
take for granted and was in place for a
long time the weekend the weekend isn't
some natural thing that just appeared
the week we have a weekend because
workers who used to be made to work
seven days a week
fought for [ __ ] 40 years and got shot
and [ __ ] fired and beaten up by the
police until they achieved the weekend
right now the weekend is being eroded
again we can talk about that if you want
but
so we are all the beneficiaries
of of these big collective struggles and
there's no
there's no trade-off between those two
things the more you gain control of
yourself personally the better able you
are to participate in a collective
struggle and the more the collective
struggle
succeeds the better the more we can set
people free to do the things that all
empower their attention anyway do you
see i mean does that i know that it
might seem
uh viscerally it's not doesn't match
with your gut instinct but does it can
you see that there's a truth in that
chris i feel like you can oh yeah
absolutely man i mean you know you are a
part of the whole there's a emergence
and the synthesis that goes on between
what you can do as an individual and the
environment that you're in and then as
you get more agency as an individual and
become more aware you can contribute to
the people around you you know
my friends make me a better person why
well because they do a thing they gain
some agency they learn about something
and then they influence me just scale
that up across a country or a nation or
a world right a species so yeah i am i
agree man i just it's that's something
that maybe me
and also a lot of the people i think
that listen to podcasts probably need to
be conscious of that personal
responsibility is something which is um
spoken about so much that it can
actually be not to a detriment but it
can blind you to some other solutions
that could be useful you know collective
solutions and um
yeah it's it's an interesting one what
about what about um
the relationship between attention and
well-being and how we actually feel does
it have a relationship to how we feel
about ourselves
oh totally so and it goes both ways
think about something like anxiety right
um
so as your ability to pay attention
degrades you're less able to achieve
your goals you have less of a sense of
what's called an internal locus of
control and finally this relates very
strongly to what you were just saying so
there's a
locus of control is your ability to feel
you can change things in your world
right
your immediate world or the wider world
and there's lots of evidence
so if you have an internal locus of
control you're someone who feels i can
make things happen right
and and then and if you have what's
called an external locus of control
that's where you feel look whatever i do
nothing will ever change i can't make
things happen right
and there's a um as you as your
attention gets worse
your locus of control begins to break
down because you're not see
think about your tic-tock as you
couldn't even play a
basketball game right what can they make
happen okay they can make their
followership rack up on tick tock
um which probably does give i'm sure
does give them a sense of agency but
they can't make things happen outside
that realm you're gonna feel incompetent
there's actually lots of ways
particularly young people
that our environment
makes people feel incompetent the way
our school system works makes boys
particularly feel incompetent uh and is
really damaging their attention their
sense of having a locus of control
there's a whole range of things we can
think about in relation to that so so
there's one level at which okay you
can't achieve your goals you become more
anxious because you're just not as
effective a person in the world there's
also another direction whereas as you
become more anxious anxiety itself
undermines attention stress undermines
attention i think a lot of this is
happening at the moment with with kovid
where without getting into the debate
about covert because of [ __ ] hell i
can't bear that the um if you think
about something that i think is
happening to all of us whatever you
think about the response to covid um
there's a woman called nadine burke
harris amazing woman she's now the
surgeon general of california the
leading medical officer in the state and
she explained this thing to me it's
helped me to think about why so many
people haven't been able to focus during
covid i remember at the start lots of
people going oh i'm gonna finally read
that 900 page book i've been meaning to
read and no [ __ ] i know read the 900
page book during copied right
um uh
and
nadine said to me once
um it was not that long before covert
although we didn't know it
she said to me okay imagine one day
you're attacked by a bear you're just
going about your business and you're
attacked by a bear in the weeks and
months that follow
involuntarily something will happen to
your attention it will flip uh it will
scan the horizon for potential risks and
dangers right just this is just a
natural thing you something's hit you
out the blue so you're going to be on
the lookout for other things that might
come out the blue so it'll be harder for
you to focus on like a book say because
a little bit of your brain or a big bit
of your brain is going what the [ __ ]
going on right is there another danger
around the corner okay now imagine
you're attacked by a bear again
then you might flip into what's called
you'll likely flip into a state called
hyper vigilance where immediate uh focus
on tasks like reading a book will be
really hard because you're just like
[ __ ] out i don't know what's going on
here i i need to scan for risks right
um
there was a great child psychiatrist
that interviewed in adelaide in
australia called dr gondradini who said
to me you know deep focus is a really
good tactic when you are safe right it
will make you help you grow it'll help
you develop your mind you'll become a
better person
but it's a [ __ ] stupid strategy if
you're in danger right if you're you'd
be a fool to sit at the battle of the
somme and read war and peace right
you're gonna get shot in the head right
so um
attempt deep attention is something we
can provide when we feel safe
and the kind of weird instability of
kovid
um
i think has put a lot of people into a
state of vigilance and hyper vigilance
partly about the virus itself partly
about their work
partly just about
what the [ __ ] happening where where
are we right um
so i think
i forgot what your question was chris
what was that how did i get onto this
we're just looking looking at how it is
that
focus and attention relate to our sense
of well-being but what you've identified
there is it's reverse it's that our
sense of well-being can influence our
ability to focus which makes sense like
think about any time that you've had a
an impending awkward conversation and
you're trying to do something to assuage
the feelings of of anxiety about the
upcoming terrible discussion with your
boss or girlfriend or whatever mate and
uh
yeah it's impossible it's absolutely
impossible and you talk about flow
states as well right
yeah i think you're right that goes in
both directions and flow states are a
really interesting example
of a form of attention that we know
massively boosts mental well-being so a
flow state everyone listening will have
experienced a flow state a flow state is
when you're doing something and you
that's meaningful to you and you really
get into it and your sense of time falls
away and your sense of ego falls away
and your attention just comes so easily
you're not even thinking about paying
attention one rock climber said uh flow
is like when you you feel like you are
the rock you're climbing right
um
and
flow states are the most deep and
precious form of attention human beings
can provide and it's particularly
important form of attention because it's
not an effortful form of attention when
you get into flow it's not like when
you're trying to learn something for an
exam and you're like oh [ __ ] hell
okay this happened then and how do i
memorize that it's completely effortless
so obviously i was thinking a lot about
how do we get into flow right how do we
get into states of flow how do we if
this is like a gusher of attention that
we all have within us how do we where do
we drill to get that that gusher right
so i went to interview my harley cheek
sent me hai who was the you have no idea
how long it took me to memorize saying
that name uh who was the he's a
i think i did the last interview he ever
did he was um he sadly died not long
afterwards
incredible man
so he was a hungarian psychologist
who
discovered coined the phrase flow states
and spent 50 years investigating them
and he discovered lots of things he
discovered crucially for your question
about well-being the more flow states
you experience the better you feel about
yourself and interestingly although
in the state of flow you have no sense
of ego
um
afterwards you have a healthier sense of
self so people there are some people
about 15 percent of people ex
very rarely experience flow states and
that correlates very highly with things
like depression anxiety uh and the more
flow states you experience the happier
you are and the more
more importantly than being happy the
more fulfilled you are
and so i was talking to him a lot about
you know
what
what's going on here how can we get flow
states and he had discovered an enormous
number of things about this but i think
for the purposes of listeners who want
to maximize their flow states there's
three things i would recommend from his
that he learned in his incredible
50-year body of research on this the
first is
there's three things you need to do to
get into a flow state the first is you
have to choose one
clear goal right
if you're trying to do more than one
thing you'll never get into flow right
so i can't say i'm gonna read this book
and i'm gonna watch the latest episode
of whatever
the one will undermine the other i mean
watching you know anyway you get the
idea um so interruption distraction or
multiple goals
[ __ ] flow
the second
is the goal has to be meaningful to you
right and this is very important
you can't flow into something that
doesn't matter to you so you could say
to me johan paint this canvas or play
this guitar or climb this rock and i
would never get into flow with that
right i would the guitar would sound
like i was killing an animal and the
rock well i would just fall off the rock
and die so there would be a flow state
because the blood would flow out of my
body but that would not be great right
so it's got to be something that matters
to you and a lot of the times when
people struggle to pay attention at work
it's often because their work is not
meaningful to them and we can talk more
about how you can build meaning into
work if you like the third
this is the one that most helped me
is if you want to maximize your chances
of getting into flow
choose something that's at the edge of
your abilities so if you're a medium
talent rock climber
you don't want to clamber over a garden
wall you're not going to flow over that
but equally you don't want to suddenly
try and climb mount kilimanjaro you're
going to just be overwhelmed you want to
choose a rock that's slightly higher and
harder than the last one you climbed
so
clear goal meaningful goal edge of your
ability there's one person who said life
begins at the edge of your comfort zone
and i think
flow states begin at the edge of your
comfort zone when you do that you
maximize your chance of flow but i would
argue and argue in the book that we're
living with
a crisis of flow states given what
mahali said
that and and scientifically proved that
to get into flow you have to be able to
do one thing and not be distracted and
given that we know the enormous quantity
of interruption that we're all exposed
to i think we're experiencing a
crippling of flow states which is one of
the reasons why it's not the only one by
any means but it's one of the reasons
why we've got higher levels of anxiety
and depression and a lot of these other
problems so they sort of feed what gets
you into flo chris what's your
podcasting is probably the closest i get
to it when it's a really good
conversation and everything just gets
forgotten about and it's you're just
here
i've found it's easier for me with
physical practices than mental ones that
reading a book reading a good book is
i can get there but it ha it's usually
fiction i struggle to get into a flow
state with a non-fiction book i find
a narrative and you can imagine the
landscape of whatever's going on inside
of your mind but you know i i play
pickleball for instance for the first
time which is kind of like
like miniature tennis with paddles and a
big ball and i played played that for
the first time in austin while i was out
there and we went for three hours and
that for me i can drop into flow state
in a physical practice super easily i
learned wake surfing while i was out
there i went shooting like um
tactic tactical shooting at targets that
all of those things i can drop into very
easily for me it's much harder to do
mentally um
but i had stephen kotler on from the
flow research collective so he looked at
the biology of flow and he said exactly
the same thing that you have if you task
switch you're looking at sort of between
15 and 20 minutes 23 minutes for you to
be able to get back into that we also
said that any type of emotion
emotional response will knock you out of
flow very quickly
and this is why
turning off notifications is so
important or if you're doing something
where you're trying to get into flow
having a constrained environment where
just you don't get external stimuli
someone sends you an email even if the
email is basically
neutral in terms of what it means to you
the fact that it's popped up will
probably give you a small sense of
annoyance you notice it or maybe there's
an excitement or there's annoyance or
whatever and that emotion is enough to
kick you out of flow so that's the same
as a task switch you know you just your
attention goes up you notice something
maybe annoys you maybe it makes you
happy maybe it doesn't do anything but
it's just a little bit of something and
then
you're out and to get yourself back into
that biologically optimal state for flow
it takes too long and yeah it's this our
days become fractured into segments so
small that we can't get anything
meaningful done but we also can't get
into a state that makes us feel
meaningful we can't get into a state
that makes us feel good so
yeah it's um
i think that's such a good way of
putting it chris i'm just thinking about
that because i i think you've put that
better than i did and the i'm just
thinking about there's so many aspects
of that it also
so part of what's going is what's
happening is that we're
exactly what you just said that that
process where we're so broken up we
can't find meaning also
we're plugged into a machinery that
diverts us into a form of meaning that
is mostly [ __ ] right so you think
about um the craving for likes and
retweets which everyone is on instagram
and twitter will experience right and
you feel good when you've got them and
you
and as recently i had this
i've had periods in my life where i've
been sort of successful on those metrics
and it and it gave me a sort of rush but
it never made me feel good the way a
flow state does
and when i was in provincetown and i had
those three months off the internet i
was really able to think about that and
i sort of had this kind of um
slightly wanky epiphany where
i was thinking a lot about because when
i was away you know i was away for this
for as long as i'd been since they were
invented right
and i was trying to think why do i feel
so much better when i'm for me reading a
book or the different people have
different flow states whether it's
playing the guitar or surfing or
whatever it might be
why do i feel so much better when i'm
doing those things than when i'm even
when i'm sort of winning at social media
right
and i had this i started thinking about
this this canadian philosopher um called
marshall mcluhan who in the 60s said
this famous thing that i had never
understood
he said the medium is the message right
which i'd obviously heard but i
i never really knew what he meant
and what he and i started reading while
i was out there and
he's been dead for many years
and mcluhan said that basically he was
talking about television when a new
medium a new way of humans communicating
is invented like television
there's obviously the specific tv show
that might have a message in it right
you can watch the wire that's got one
message you can watch wheel of fortune
that's got a different message right
but whether you watch the wire or wheel
of fortune
the medium itself has a message in it if
you watch a television you begin to see
the world as being like television even
think about something as simple as like
how we think about our own memories as
like flashbacks in a tv show right like
when you think about your childhood you
picture it i picture it as like a
flashback in a tv show people didn't
think about memory that way before
television was invented they also have
memories and they but they process them
in different ways right so when a medium
comes along it changes how you see the
world it's like putting on a new set of
goggles and you start to see the world
through that medium i think that's what
he was saying i couldn't be
misunderstanding him
but
i started thinking about that in
relation to say twitter or instagram
right
um
because
what is the message hidden in the medium
of twitter right it doesn't matter if
you're donald trump or bernie sanders or
bubba the love sponge
when you
tweet
you are buying into an implicit set of
messages the first is
the world can and should be described in
280 characters that is a useful valuable
way of predominantly thinking about the
world right
um and the second is that what matters
is whether people immediately agree
with your 280 character characterization
of the world right
or think about instagram where the
message is what matters is how you look
and whether people immediately like how
you look
and i was thinking about it and i mean
i mean i like looking at people who look
good but with twitter
so i thought i one of the reasons i
don't feel good even when i'm winning in
that game
is because i don't think that's true i
think that underlying message is really
wrong actually
i i don't think many things that are
useful can be said in 280 characters in
fact almost nothing maybe if you're a
[ __ ] japanese haiku artist all right
but i don't see many of them on twitter
um and actually
whether people immediately agree with
you
is a very bad metric for measuring the
value of what you think and say right
actually almost everyone i admire
the first time they started saying what
they said people didn't agree with them
if everyone immediately agrees with you
it probably didn't need to be said
actually everyone already knew it right
um and and the same with instagram that
there's a value in people looking good
um
but if that becomes you know essentially
after i wrote my book about depression
lost connections i cannot tell you how
many messages i got on instagram from
people with enormous instagram
followings these like stunningly
beautiful you know porn stars sadly all
women uh if the male porn stars want to
get in touch they're very welcome to um
that who just feel like [ __ ] and if you
looked at their instagram they're the
ones that are winning in the game right
because this is a very bad metric to
dominate your life it's a perfectly good
metric some of the time
in a way i don't think twitter is ever a
good metric i think looking good is good
um
but
these messages are not good and then i
thought well when i read books i feel
very physical books
i feel quite different and i think
what's the message in a book
irrespective of you know the specific
words of that particular book the
message is
firstly slow down
right just slow down think about one
thing for like you know a book it'll
take you seven ten hours whatever it is
it's worth thinking about just one thing
for ten hours that's a pretty [ __ ]
radical message in the world we live in
right um secondly um you might want to
think especially what you said about
fiction
one of the messages is
think about other people's internal
lives
stop and think about this you might read
a novel about someone who's really
different to you
um but they've got an internal life just
like you you realize that we're in fact
incredibly similar i just read a book
about like a chinese peasant and you
were going like oh you know you see
written by somebody i've been a chinese
person like oh right where you know you
start to see the similarities the
differences um
that to me that messages about slowness
and depth
those are things that are actually worth
having that people get them in different
ways doesn't have to be a physical book
um
but slowness and depth are things that
are worth having if everyone listening
if you think about something you've
achieved in your life
it will be because you slowed down you
focused deeply you paid attention it
will not be because you thought in quick
rapid [ __ ] bursts and loads of people
gave you hearts that's not
but you know you if you are happy when
if that if you think that's your
greatest achievement then you're gonna
have quite an unhappy life right does
that does that ring true to you chris
yeah man there's a quote from naval that
says play stupid games win stupid prizes
what do you mean i love that what
naval ravikant he's an investor from
silicon valley and just one of the
smartest guys on the planet uh and play
stupid games win stupid prizes what is
the prize that you get for winning at
the game that you're currently playing
what's the prize that you get for always
keeping your instagram dm requests
folder at zero what's the prize that you
get for always being the person that
replies the quickest in the whatsapp
chat what's the prize that you get for
being the person that gets retweets on
twitter
okay like you know if you're trying to
grow your company's [ __ ] instagram
account because you think that you're
going to be able to change the world and
clean up the seas because that's what it
does maybe you know that's a good way to
do it but most people don't realize what
the prize is for winning the game that
they're playing and if you looked at it
you wouldn't want to win that prize
anyway what's the prize for texting
while you drive because you want to be
the first person to respond in the group
chat to that [ __ ] meme that you've seen
before like with a [ __ ] emoji like we
have to question around what it is that
we're trying to do and why we're playing
those games you mentioned earlier on
actually about sleep what's how does
sleep relate to focus
well i spent a lot of time interviewing
some of the leading experts in the world
on this and it's
[ __ ] chilling um
the guy i mentioned before dr charles
seisler who's at harvard medical school
amazing man
he did this experiment that really
haunted me
he combined two bits of technology that
had not been combined to look at sleep
before
one is there's a technology that can
scan your eyes to see what you're
looking at and there's another kind of
technology that can obviously scan your
brain
and he put them together and he put in
people into this machinery who were
tired not completely [ __ ] knackered
they've been awake for 19 hours
and what he found was really chilling
so basically you can appear to be awake
you're looking around you you're talking
just as surely as we're talking now
but what the brain scan showed is that
significant parts of their brain were
literally asleep so he discovered this
phenomenon it's called local sleep it's
called local because it's local to one
part of the brain
um so
and this has all sorts of catastrophic
effects on attention so if you have been
awake for 19 hours your attention is as
impaired as if you were legally drunk
this is why drowsy driving is is one of
the biggest causes of death if you if
you factor in drowsy driving and
distracted driving they're just enormous
causes of death um
and and so i wanted to speak to people
out well why is it right because the
evidence is overwhelming two things a
if you don't sleep your attention will
be [ __ ] even if you just sleep six
hours a night for a week your attention
gets to the point as if you're legally
drunk and b
we sleep much less than we did in the
past
so i was thinking about okay well what
what can that you know
why why is why is that happening right
a person who really helped me to
understand this is an amazing woman
called professor roxanne prichard who's
at the university of minneapolis where i
interviewed her
and she said she explained to me
um
it used to be thought that sleep was a
passive process right
so i'm not using my arm muscles right
now they're inert right as you can see
it i don't ever use them um apart from
occasionally to lift books or big macs
but
it used to be thought that when you were
asleep your brain was sort of like that
it was inert it was passive it's not
doing much right it's why sleep wasn't
studied scientifically for a long time
then it was discovered
when various new technologies came along
that made it possible to do this that
sleep is an incredibly active process
lots of things are happening when you
are asleep your brain is repairing it's
healing itself it's clearing out the
metabolic waste that builds up during
the day and it takes it down to your
liver and flushes it out all sorts of
absolutely necessary physical processes
happen during sleep there's one expert
who said um
it's a bit like having a house party you
can either have uh the guests in your
house or you can clean the house but you
can't do both at the same time
for whatever reason your brain can't
repair itself while you're awake and
doing all the work you need to do while
you're awake right
um so what we've done is we've radically
cut back on the amount of time we allow
our brains to rest and repair
and as roxanna explained to me professor
prashad explained to me
you know your brain you can live and do
that right of course we wouldn't have
survived hurricanes or been able to
raise babies if we couldn't go without
sleep but she said when you go without
sleep your body interprets that as an
emergency it's like oh i must be fleeing
a hurricane i must be tending to a sick
child whatever it is and it goes into
all sorts of emergency modes it will
make you crave more sugar and more fatty
food to give you more quick release
energy it will raise your heartbeat it
will raise your blood pressure
and it will cut back on all the kind of
longer term forms of thinking like
creativity free association all sorts of
things that we need to be people who can
think deeply right because if you've got
an imminent threat you don't want to be
thinking about your 10-year goals you
need to presumably be hiding from the
tiger that's outside of the cave exactly
when a tiger's chasing you you're not
worried about how you're going to pay
the rent right it's cutting back on all
of those worries um but what's happening
is many of us are living
in that bodily emergency right we're
living
you know i mean roxanne was really
struck by her students she's incredibly
engaging
brilliant lecturer but her students she
noticed how many of them would just fall
asleep and she talked to her colleagues
and like was happening in all their
classes and she she then studied these
students and discovered that the average
college student slept as much
as the average parent of a newborn baby
or the average active duty soldier and
when she began trying to explain to them
what they were doing
uh she realized that they had just been
raised in an environment where sleep
deprivation is the norm what were the
sort of numbers on that do you know
i know the figures generally i can't
remember for college students but the
figures are staggering for britain 23 of
british people sleep five hours a night
right that is
devastating for their ability to think
to pay attention
and again that's related to lots of
things that are going on some of that is
related to stress
work stress the inability to unplug
anxiety there's a whole range of things
that are going on there some of it's
related to poor slight sleep hygiene you
know
and dr seisler harvard did a lot of
research on this that i thought was
really interesting
so basically um
he's the person who identified what's
called the second surge of energy so
imagine if you were
um well our ancestors but imagine you
analogous situation to a situation our
ancestors found ourselves in imagine you
go camping and it starts to get dark
just as it starts to get dark
uh you get a fresh surge of energy in
your in your your body as it starts to
get dark
because you know that means you and
obviously that means you can put up your
tent right and you can see how that
would have been very useful for our
ancestors oh it started to get dark
let's give them a surge of energy so
they can get back together they're still
five miles away from wherever the rest
of the camp is we need to run back okay
so we'll give them an extra kick that'll
get them over this little hump as things
are getting darker and more dangerous
they get back home they can fall asleep
exactly there's a very good evolved
reason for that for that to happen which
exactly as you describe what sorry do
you know what the um surge
is of
do you know what is being released
at that time i think it's all the things
that give you energy i'm sure he did
tell me but it's five years since i met
him four years since i met him i can't
remember but
all the things that normally give human
beings energy i assume adrenaline but i
would want to double check that um
and
obviously for almost all of human
existence
we we had no say over when it got dark
right that was just a fact of nature we
could light fires but that was it
but obviously with the rise of
electronic light
now we decide when the sunset happens
right there's obviously the the physical
sunset but then there's when we turn out
the lights
and the difficulty is if you're sitting
there staring at your phone or your
laptop or your television until midnight
and then you turn out the lights and it
goes dark what happens is you experience
that second surge of energy you're lying
there and suddenly your body's like oh
it just got dark
we need to help him get back to the camp
right but you're already in your camp
you're in your bed right so this is why
and it's one reason one of the reasons
our control over electronic light is
having such a negative effect on our
sleep as as dr seissler said
human beings are as sensitive to light
as algae
you know we
we
[Music]
light profoundly alters our bodily
processes
and our control over light is obviously
a great gift for all sorts of blindingly
obvious reasons
um but it is having this this effect so
one of the things we need to do
is have a
um have different forms of hygiene
around this so you know everyone gets
recommended this but it really does help
don't look at
blue shining light the light from your
laptop and phone for two hours before
you go to bed
because it will wake you up and it will
also mean that when you do sleep your
sleep is less good quality
or there's plenty of other things that
are going on with sleep i went to in
montreal i interviewed professor torren
nielsen who runs the dream lab at the
university of montreal that was a great
just description of a job like i'm the
head of the dream lab but um
and he discovered that another thing
that's um really bad for us is
um
about this decline in sleep is
there's lots of evidence that dreaming
helps you to process emotional events
you can you experience something without
being flooded with stress hormones and
just you make connections when you're
dreaming
and the most intense stage of dreaming
rem sleep tends to happen in the seventh
and eighth hours of sleep so from seven
hours on
but of course most of us are now not
experiencing that and i remember sitting
there with him and thinking god what
does it mean that we've become a society
where we literally don't give ourselves
time to dream
right and that has all sorts of knock-on
effects for anxiety which causes
attention problems but
across the board
and it was interesting at some level
people know this like i commissioned the
yougov to do the first ever opinion poll
of why people think if and why people
think their attention is getting worse
and we identify people who think their
attention is getting worse
and
ask them why do you think that is and we
gave them 10 options
and interestingly the decline of sleep
was by was number one
it was 48 of people it was tied 48 of
people said sleep and 48 of people said
a change in life events like having a
baby or getting older though but
interestingly tech our relationship with
tech was fourth which i thought was
really interesting the third one was
stress but we've said so far we've kind
of laid
a lot of the problems kind of in and
around the feet of technology right and
technology's ubiquitous in our lives you
basically can't escape it so it kind of
makes sense that it would be pretty
pervasive throughout everything but you
said that you thought there was a
number one
reason for our loss of attention that
wasn't technology what was that i think
there's quite a lot i would agree with
the opinion part i think sleep is ahead
of it i think stress is ahead of it i
think probably the biggest although it's
the one over which there's
some scientific uncertainty i if you put
a gun to my head and said 100 years from
now if they're still people and they can
still think uh when they look back at us
and they think we had an attention
crisis what will they attribute it to
it might well be air pollution
so
i introduced lots of scientists about
this and it was really chilling if you
just live in any city
you are currently breathing in a huge
amount of air pollution
and
one of the things professor barbara marr
at the university of lancaster has done
some of the best work on this
um when you breathe in these pollutants
like iron so let's say iron is a
pollutant that's in the air that
everyone listening is not in a very
rural place is breathing in
um that cause so you breathe it in and
the iron goes straight to your brain
nothing in our evolution prepared us for
iron
coming into our brain that way it causes
brain inflammation
um
and
the way professor mar described it is it
causes a repeated chronic insult to the
brain so we know we have emerging
evidence about this so for example uh
people who live close to a main road
there's a study in canada of this
um were radically more likely to develop
dementia because of this repeated
chronic insult to the brain so we have
at that end of life we have evidence at
the other end of life we have evidence
as well which is um there's a really
disturbing study studies in barcelona
and mexico city
children who live in highly polluted
areas
when they did brain studies of them
literally had plaques and tangles in
their brain that were like the plaques
and tangles early stages of dementia
um so we're exposed to a huge amount of
pollution not just in
air pollution but also in um
flame retardants uh professor barbara
domini is the leading expert on this
flame retardants pesticides plasticizers
and to be honest i've always been
someone who thought that was a load of
[ __ ] when i heard people complaining
about that i thought it was like kind of
neurotic hippie [ __ ] and but when i
looked at the evidence
it was quite chilling actually what can
people do let's say that someone does
live in a city is there anything that we
can do on an individual level to help
mitigate that
so that's what i asked all the experts
and the answer was quite chilling which
was
i mean well the way professor dominique
said to me
said it to me is
look you can eat organic you can you
know shut your windows
you can't escape this stuff in the
current environment we've created but
what you can do and there's a great
example of this and i think this is
really in terms of thinking about the
solutions obviously we're talking a lot
about the individual solutions as well
which is really valuable but
give you an example from the recent past
right i just remember this from when i
was a kid but
older listeners will remember
so in the 70s
it was very common for people to use
lead in paint in their houses loaded
paint
and um
a lot of cars had leaded petrol right
and then it was discovered it'd actually
been known for a long time but the lead
industry denied it but by the 70s it was
undeniable that lead [ __ ] your brain
right exposure to lead uh for children
causes really severe attention problems
in fact the exposure to lead
was so great in the 60s that it's almost
certainly why there was a huge spike in
violence in the 60s there's a big
scientific debate about this but i think
it's quite persuasive because lead
causes attention problems and
disinhibition which in some people
causes violence so you can really track
lead exposure and violent murders and
they they track very well together right
so by the 70 i mean this has been known
about since [ __ ] ancient rome but the
lead industry suppressed the evidence
denied it funded a load of fake science
by the 70s it was so clear
that
people started to organize campaigns
here in britain there was a a woman
[ __ ] what was her name
amazing woman um renee what's her last
name it'll come to me in a minute who uh
gene renee that was the name who um
was just like [ __ ] hell my kids are
being poisoned and launched a campaign
to get rid of leaded petrol which
succeeded right that now the load of
petrol is banned pretty much everywhere
in the world almost everywhere and
leaded paint is gone now it's important
to say we did not stop painting our
houses and we did not stop driving cars
right
we just moved and this is really and i
think it's a really good analogy for
social media because it's very easy to
think oh social media came along and
it's [ __ ] my attention
and i'm not going to join the amish and
give up social media so i'm just [ __ ]
right actually
it's not
there's a degree to which these
technologies would always increase
distractions to some extent
but we're in uh particularly we're in a
situation where
the
the current business models
of that drive these apps are the primary
driver of the problem so if you open
facebook
now um
facebook starts to make money in two
ways the first is obvious we all know
about you see ads second way is much
more valuable everything you do on
facebook is scanned and sorted by the
algorithms so let's say that you like
kylie minogue
donald trump and you say to your mom
you've just bought nappies okay so the
algorithm figures out if you're a man
and you like kylie minogue you're
probably gay if you like donald trump
you're probably right wing and if you're
talking about nappies you've probably
got a baby right
it's got tens of thousands of data
points like this it's building them up
all the time
in order because you're not the customer
of facebook you're the product they sell
you to the advertisers so the
advertisers can target you because if
i'm selling nappies i don't want you
don't send an advert to me and you we
don't have babies you want to send it
someone who's got babies right
um
the minute you close facebook
facebook loses both of those revenue
streams
so the primary in fact the entire motive
of facebook
is to maximize the amount of time you
spend scrolling right that's what all
the engineers all the algorithms are
designed to do to maximize the amount of
time you spend scrolling that's their
goal but in the same way that their ceo
of kfc all he cares about is did chris
eat fried chicken this week
all the people who run facebook care
about is how many hours
did chris spend on facebook
so that means we currently have a
machinery that is designed to maximally
invade people's attention right
it has to to make its money right and
this is not the view of kind of radical
outsiders to facebook this is what
facebook themselves admit sean parker
one of the biggest initial investors in
facebook said you know when we designed
it we designed it to maximally raid
people's attention
we knew what we were doing and we did it
anyway god only knows what it's doing to
our kids brains that's what he said
right we've now got a lot of leaked
information from facebook revealing all
sorts of dark things
but
i remember first learning that it took
me a long time to get my head around
that i was interviewing lots of
dissonance in silicon valley
and then
they kept explaining to me
but don't you see this makes the
solution easier not harder
it's the problem isn't the paint and the
petrol the problem is the lead in the
paint and the petrol and in the same way
that business model is the primary
problem there are different ways social
media could work
where it could be designed not to hack
your attention but to heal your
attention
acer asking who designed key aspects of
how the internet works explained to me
look the thing we need to do is you need
to ban the current business model just
like we banned lead in petrol you need
to say a business model premise on
scanning and surveilling people to build
up data on them to sell that information
to advertisers to hack their attention
that's just an inhuman model and we
won't allow it but i remember saying to
all these people who were saying this to
me
well okay let's imagine we did that what
happens the day after when i open
facebook does it just say sorry we've
gone fishing and he said they said of
course not facebook would move to a
different business model it could be
like netflix you pay a small sum every
month
and you're on facebook or it could be
like the sewage system everyone
listening you know we used to not have
sewers we got [ __ ] in the streets and
cholera
we all paid for the sewers to be built
and we all own them together
it might be
that just like we own the sewage pipes
we want to own the information pipes
together because we're getting the
attentional equivalent of cholera but
whatever the alternative business model
is and there's many possible
configurations
the important thing is it changes the
incentives of the social media companies
themselves
once we've got that model you're not the
product anymore you're the customer so
they have to think about not how do i
sell chris to someone else how do i sell
chris's attention how do i maximally
invade it they have to think what does
chris want oh chris wants to be able to
see his friends why don't we put in a
button that says
uh i'd like to meet up with my friends
is anyone around who wants to meet up
they might start saying
it's all sorts of ways facebook can be
redesigned not to hack your attention
but to heal your attention but to do
that we've got to change the business
incentives and i know that can seem like
a big thing but james williams the guy
we mentioned before the google engineer
said former google engineer said to me
you know the axe existed for 1.4 million
years before anyone thought to put a
handle on it the entire internet has
existed for less than 10 000 days
we can change the way these things work
now that's a fight that's a big fight
facebook isn't going to do it on its own
facebook isn't even dealing with the
most [ __ ]
heinous things they do their own
internal research discovered
that a third of all the people who
joined neo-nazi groups in germany
did it because facebook's algorithms
specifically recommended it you might
want to join
um and they're not even dealing with
that if they won't deal with that on
their own promoting nazism they they're
not going to deal with this on their own
but they will if we make in the same way
the lead industry wasn't going to stop
putting lead in your paint right they
had to be made to do it but we can make
them we can make them do it you're
igniting my inner uh activist
honestly it's it's just it's a it's a
mode of thinking that i usually don't
think about but i i i appreciate that
that type of insight and to me it fits
with what you your wider way think about
these things chris because it's a way of
you know
it's a way of challenging our
self-conception because at the moment i
do think we're in quite a victory
mindset about attention we just go oh
i'm not good enough
oh i'm i'm weak and to me it's like
we're saying to people you are we are
not medieval peasants begging at the
court of king zuckerberg for a few
little crumbs of attention from his
table
we are the free citizens of we are the
free citizens of democracies we own our
own minds and we can take them back from
the [ __ ] who've stolen them right we
are dignified people who own our minds
and we will not allow them to be hacked
and invaded in this way and we won't
allow our kids to be [ __ ] hacked and
invaded in this way you talk about some
of the framing to do with how we
perceive our own attention you talk
about cruel optimism what's that
yeah so cruel optimism
and this is a very difficult line to
tread it comes back to what we were
saying before
so
cruel optimism is where you take
something it was a phrase by the way
invented by a guy called lauren berlant
who was an american historian um
cruel optimism is where you take
something with really big causes like
attention crisis
and you offer a really small solution
we've all been told something like if
you just open this meditation app for 10
minutes a day you'll get your attention
back or solve all these problems of
distraction
and i'm in favor of meditation strongly
and i talk about the work in the book in
the ways in which building slow
practices into your life boosts your
attention
but the reason so it sounds like
optimism you're saying to the person
i've got a solution for you the reason
it's cruel
is because it's so small it will almost
certainly fail it might give them some
boost but it won't solve the problem and
it probably will give them a boost but
it won't solve the problem
and the problem is if you've oversold it
at the start
what that person will then think is
oh [ __ ] up
i did the solution right i did the thing
you're meant to do
and i'm still [ __ ] and i still can't pay
attention there must be something wrong
with me
so and and that's why it turns into
cruel optimism so what you want to do is
um
the alternative to cruel optimism is not
pessimism this is very important to
stress right uh pessimism is the enemy
of getting anything done
the alternative to cruel optimism
is authentic optimism
which is where you say to people you
explain truthfully the scale of the
problem
and you build tools to tackle the
problem at every level right which is
individual and collective and and you
explain to people how we can do that
and i i get really worried about cruel
optimism because
um
i think it i think it [ __ ] people over
and i think there's a
you know writing the book about a guy
called neriel have you had near on your
podcast i think you might have done yeah
i have and the interesting thing is that
you mentioned i haven't listened to the
audio bit that you've put on your
website you mentioned the conversation
with him got heated my conversation with
him didn't get heated but there was
something about indistractible which was
the book that we were talking about
there was something about it that didn't
resonate with me and i couldn't really
work out what it was at the time um and
i think that the cruel optimism part of
it
i think that i feel
so
much distaste toward social media
companies and technology at large
that as soon as somebody says well you
know this technology is essentially an
ambivalent tool it's all about how you
interpret it you know this is on you i'm
like no i i want to be able to take
responsibility for my technology use
but i don't want you to ever try and say
that these companies on the technology
that we have is impartial they're not
they're not they're racing to the bottom
of our brain stems to try and reduce the
amount of free sovereign time that we
have during our brief window of
consciousness while we're alive on this
planet like it is the most predatory of
predatory uh institutions and i i don't
know i can't fully remember the book
about what we spoke about but there was
something that didn't resonate and i
wonder how much sort of that
was a genesis of your disagreement with
him as well that is super interesting
because um
so just to explain people who don't know
nirial is an american uh very
influential american tech designer
um
the ceo of microsoft has held up his
work and told everyone to read it that
that level of not indestructible by the
way it was his other one hooked which is
how to design addictive products well
this is the this is exactly it so
and to be fair to near
i'm offering my summary of what he what
he thinks i suspect he would disagree
with it so anyone who wants to you can
go to stalinfocusbook.com and listen to
the full audio of the conversation i
have with him um where he expresses his
view in greater length at greater length
but
so near wrote a book called
indistractible
which uh argues primarily not entirely
he does think there are some um
some forms of regulation that should be
introduced but he argues overwhelmingly
the solution is solely that you change
your individual behavior as he put it to
me you know every phone has a button
that can says do not disturb he said
it's really simple push the [ __ ]
button right that was the phrase he used
um and he
uh
he argues for a whole series of
individual changes many of which i agree
with some of which i've implemented into
my own life
but he
um
my discomfort with it became clearer
when i read his previous book called
hooked
try to remember the subtitle it's
something like how to build
habit-forming products he describes it
as a cookbook for human behavior and
it's a guide for tech designers
to make
habit-forming products
and
um it could really be summarized the
message a bit
i think i mean this is probably a bit
unfair but part of it could be
summarized by a headline he wrote on his
blog advice to tech designers
want to hook your users drive them crazy
and what i felt very uncomfortable it's
a weird thing reading indistractible as
an ordinary user of the internet it's
like the moment at the end of the batman
film where they catch the villain and he
explains how he did it all along you
know like what he was doing step by step
it's it's it's quite disconcerting
because you sort of realize oh [ __ ]
that's happened to me right
and when i spoke to near what i was
trying to draw out
was the disjunction between these two
books right you've got indestructible
which says this is a push the [ __ ]
button it's an easy thing you can do it
and then you've got hooked which is
saying let's drive them crazy we can
really get into their heads we can make
them crave our products he describes an
imaginary woman called julie he said if
she's standing in a line we want to get
her we want to get her to deal with her
anxiety by turning into our product
right
and and yet in in indestructible he says
things like picture yourself as a leaf
on a river imagine yourself floating
down the river and i'm like
bit of a disjunction between the most
powerful [ __ ] machinery in the world
and picture yourself as a leaf on a
river right well that's what tristan
harris from the center for humane
technology says right he says for all
that you think that you can use your
willpower that you can try and finagle
your device to work so that you don't
press the next button behind every
button press there's a thousand
engineers using the most powerful
artificial intelligence algorithms on
the planet to try and get you to push it
it's a hopelessly unwinnable wall
exactly and tristan's a good friend of
mine and obviously i spent a lot of time
interviewing him for the book and i
think he's a one of the [ __ ] heroes
of our time
and i think he's absolutely right
um and especially tristan and and near
both went to the same
this course at stanford which used to be
called a course in mind control but then
they thought that sounded a bit sinister
persuasive technologies yeah something
else is that the persuasive technologies
lab yeah um which is um it's basically
so many of the key figures who remade
the world in silicon valley went through
this course which teaches you how to use
methods of persuasion and control
um
in technology
and but i do think we are in this mode
now
uh
where
the tech companies are going to
systematically try to
transfer responsibility for the problems
they have caused onto us right they want
us to think about it as you're something
wrong with you your floor we're going to
be the benevolent people who give you
the tools to deal with your problem
right
um
and again some of those tools will be
useful i'm not disputing that
but
they are much more the problem than the
solution well the thing is that the the
problem is much more slippery and much
more addictive than the solutions are
it's the same as a company releasing a
new type of food which is just amazing
and beautiful and
full of fat and
processed to [ __ ] and it's going to make
you gain loads of weight and say yeah
yeah i know that we released that but
we've also released some apples and you
can go and have the apples and you go
well look there is an asymmetry in the
weaponization of these types of food
you've designed one of these types of
foods to be incredibly addictive and the
other one yes you're right i can use
that to no longer if i ate that i
wouldn't need to eat the addictive one
but the problem is that there's an
asymmetry in the weaponizing of this one
is much more slippery it's the same
reason that conspiracy theories get more
traction online versus the truth
conspiracy theories hijack our attention
in a way that the truth simply can't and
that's why they get propagated so much
more quickly and it's why it's dangerous
to share conspiracy theories well but i
think you've gone to really i mean
there's several things what you just
said you're right it's like your dealer
saying to you well i'd like to offer you
some crack and a nice bottle of water
which one do you want
yes um but the but your but your
thing you said about anger and
conspiracy theories is really important
because again something that surprised
me saying i learned from tristan and
other people
is how much um
so there's a degree to which what you
said is absolutely true
conspiracy theories or attention uh you
know are inherently eye-catching right
to a lot of people particularly in the
circumstances where we live at the
moment where people have been really
disempowered and made to feel like [ __ ]
um
but there's also a degree to which the
current business model maximally
promotes
um
conspiracy theories and things that make
us feel like [ __ ] and it comes back to
so i think i think what we're saying
about before
the the um
the sole goal of facebook is to keep you
scrolling that's it that's their goal
right it's all they care about
so all of their algorithms all of their
engineers things tristan is describing
are constantly scanning what keeps
people scrolling versus what makes
people put down facebook
and these algorithms this wasn't the
intention of anyone at facebook
it's important to stress that it's not
like they're they're not like bond
villains but what the algorithm stumbled
upon is an underlying human truth it's
been known about by psychologists for a
long time it's called negativity bias
negativity bias
anyone who's ever seen a car accident on
the motorway knows what negativity
biases you stare longer at something
that's angering and upsetting than you
do at the pretty flowers on the other
side of the road right
frightening things catch our eye and we
stare at them it's useful right
evolutionary it was much more important
for us to know where the thing that
could kill us was than where the thing
that might keep us alive the thing that
keeps us alive only keeps us a bit more
alive but the thing that kills us makes
us a lot more dead yeah the people in
the past who stared at the pretty
flowers more than the dangerous thing
they didn't get to be our ancestors for
obvious reasons right but that has a
horrendous effect when it meets
algorithms designed to keep people
scrolling
because
what the algorithms discovered is
if i show you things that make you angry
and upset you will engage for longer
than if i show you things that make you
feel good so think about that just at
the level of imagine two teenage girls
who go to a house party and they leave
and they get the same bus home and one
of them
does a facebook status update where they
go that was a really nice party everyone
looked good i enjoyed it and the other
one goes karen was a [ __ ] hoe at that
party she stank and her boyfriend's a
[ __ ] and you know i spent a lot of time
with my niece looking at her social
media so i'm overly familiar with the
techniques of teenage girls on social
media and so the algorithm will put the
first app status update it will put it
in some people's
feeds
but it'll put the second one it scans
for angry and outraging words it'll put
far more of them into people's feeds
because if people see the one going it
was quite nice some people might just
click like and move on but the one
that's karen's a [ __ ] hoe
loads of people like how can you say
karen's a [ __ ] oh you're so right
karen is a [ __ ] you know you can see
how that if it's enraging it's engaging
and they want to increase engagement now
that's disastrous enough
at the level of teenagers at house party
but what's happened is that dynamic has
happened to the whole [ __ ] society
it's why countries as different as
britain and brazil about as different as
countries can be
have been ripped apart it's one of the
reasons not the only one
why
our countries are being ripped apart by
division why we are screaming hatred at
each other the whole [ __ ] time you
know why we're hardening into these
tribes that despise each other while
we're losing the space to have common
conversations to speak to each other in
sane ways you know
we're plugged into a machinery that is
that is constantly you know even in very
extreme situations continues to ramp up
hatred this the un has pointed out that
during the genocide in myanmar
facebook's algorithms were key factor in
that because if you were tweeting about
kill the rohingya
the algorithm was promoting you versus
people who were saying let's not kill
the rohingya they're our brothers right
so this is a disastrous um consequence
and
of all the leaks from facebook i thought
the most revealing and the most chilling
was the one related to this
so
in the wake of the victories of
president trump and a brexit um facebook
commissioned its own data scientist to
look into well had we played a role in
polarization
and we now have the report it was leaked
and the report found
that
uh facebook's algorithms
inevitably and eluctably promote anger
and rage
and that the only way that facebook
could deal with that would be to abandon
its current business model and adopt
what they called a de-growth strategy
where they said we're not going to
[ __ ] set the world on fire
and we'll make a bit less money they
would still by the way be unimaginably
rich
um
and and will actually not be like
causing this horrific effect and there's
a very dry when the wall street journal
reported on this leaked information
they hope they wrote that was very funny
they just said in their news report
after reading the report mark zuckerberg
asked that he not be brought any more
reports like this in the future right
that was their response it's just don't
[ __ ] tell me right um
which is incredible when you think about
how mark zuckerberg's own
you know relatives had to flee
anti-semitic persecution not that long
ago they're one of the biggest promoters
of vile anti-semitism in the world at
the moment um so yeah this this this
anger machine is another reason and this
comes to one of the
things i really was left with towards
the end of the book which is a sense of
whatever you want to deal with in your
personal life or politically
we've got to deal with this crisis first
james williams who have been quoting a
lot he said to me it's like you're
driving somewhere and someone's just
throwing a [ __ ] bucket of mud over
your windshield
it doesn't matter what you've got to do
when you get to wherever you're driving
first of all you've got to clean the
windshield if you don't do that you
can't do anything right everything is
mediated by these technologies right and
everything else is mediated by our
ability to pay attention so we said at
the very beginning you have this sort of
topology of the spotlight the starlight
the daylight and then the stadium light
and all of these are getting fractured
and fragmented and then even the ways in
which you consume information that you
hope is going to be able to fix your
attention is mediated by these
technologies too and that's where i i
think you have managed to to like i say
ignite the the activist inside of me uh
and you're like okay yeah there's so far
that i can take this myself but there's
an upper bound and if i'm operating in a
really really suboptimal environment
this is not going to be
particularly good so what what after
having done all of this research and
stuff
what strategies have you applied to your
own life
to try and retain
regain a bit of attention i sleep much
more
um
i i sleep eight hours a night now which
i didn't do before
um i sometimes think more than that
actually quite often
um i've got the k-safe i lock it away
i've got freedom on my on my
uh phone um i when i feel my attention
fracturing i don't do what i did before
which is going are you
[ __ ] why can't you do this you're just
weak
i pull back and i try to identify why
can't i focus at this moment it's
usually
um because i'm not in the right zone for
flow so i pull back and i go okay
do one thing at a time
is the thing you're doing meaningful to
you sometimes when my focus breaks down
it's actually a useful sign if i'm when
i'm writing a chapter and my focus
breaks down often it sounds like
actually at some level you know you're
not right what you're saying here the
meaning isn't right you you're wrong
actually sometimes the lack of attention
can be a healthy signal and i try to do
something at the edge of my ability so
i'm the next book i'm writing
is about a series of horrific crimes in
las vegas i've been researching that's
[ __ ] at the edge of my ability it's
not like this book right so i kind of go
okay what can i do that's at the edge of
my ability how can i push myself which
seems counterintuitive when your
attention is breaking down you
instinctively do something harder yeah
but actually the heart and the rest is
important and i'm unbelievably bad at
that and i've got a whole chapter about
the places in new zealand that moved to
a four day week and achieved more in
four days than five
um and we could talk about everyone but
the
but but uh so i and there are plenty of
things i should do and i want to be
candid about i don't do because you know
self-help books have this structure
that's like
dear reader i had this problem i did the
following 10 things and now look i'm
this perfect god-like phenomenon and the
truth is that's it would be [ __ ] for
me to say that right the particle is a
collective problem partly because i'm a
flawed person so i should have improved
my diet i should have moved away from
carb heavy uh you know fast food to
to i'm a bit better than i used to be
but only a little bit and there is
literally
behind my laptop there's a kfc bag so it
gives you some sense it's not perfect
um
uh so there's lots of other things i
should have done that i haven't done i
mean i take very long breaks from social
media and i announced in advance that
i'm doing it because you'd feel like a
right [ __ ] if you said i'm gonna be off
twitter for the next two months and then
a week later you pop up again and when i
do that i get a friend of mine to change
my password so i even if i crack in the
night i can't get in
um so i take very long deliberate breaks
so there's a whole range of things that
i talk about lots more in the book but
but uh i meditate um i was doing yoga
until covered and then i couldn't see my
teacher
um you know there's other things i
should rest more and and work less i'm
i'm very bad at that um
uh so there's a whole range of i mean
sleep is the basically the form of rest
that i increased the other stuff i just
i can't do i'm not good at it um so yeah
there's a whole range of things that we
can do and i would say that has
really deeply boosted my my attention
like properly it's a lot better than it
was before i went to graceland and what
about collective solutions what do we
need to do as a
community so i think there's a huge
range of things i think we've got to
have a movement and i would say the top
three things i would recommend would be
we've got a ban this surveillance sorry
we've got to ban this business model of
surveillance capitalism that is premised
on hacking our attention and replace it
with the other models which can make it
possible to heal our attention i would
say that
um
i would say we've gotta
ban the [ __ ] pollutants that are
inflaming our brains that's relatively
easy to do and there's plenty of
historical precedence for that think
about what happened with the ozone layer
there was the thing that was [ __ ] up
the ozone layer cfcs yeah we ban them
the ozone layer is now healing right uh
we could have the equivalent for that
the third is saying we haven't talked
about but um relates to children um
and i think we've got a deal with this
right where it begins with children's
attention problems uh and i would the
very first thing i would recommend is we
need to restore childhood right
children develop an ability to pay
attention when they play freely with
other children and that has all but
ended and it ended before covid the
the although it's obviously got worse
during covid um
only 10 of children now ever play
outside their homes without adult
supervision
that's a and go through the evidence
it's a longer conversation we should do
another podcast but
that is one of the key factors why our
children can't pay attention we have
deprived them of the thing that the
scientific evidence shows is absolutely
crucial for children being able to learn
how to deploy their attention think
uh look at you know not be anxious it's
a horror show there's you can do
experiments with rats a guy called
professor xavier castellano so i
interviewed has done work on this
you deprive er infant rats and
adolescent rats of the ability to play
with other adolescent rats
and by the time they grow up that they
can't solve problems they're much less
good at it that and you can see this
happening right you can see what's
happening with young people all the time
at the moment so i would say bands of
violence capitalism get these [ __ ]
pollutants out of the air
and and restore childhood would be my
three big initial goals but then there's
like would you put an age restriction on
the use of technology
yeah i mean i wouldn't want to go down
the chinese route of you know the
chinese government one hour a week at
the moment between eight and nine pm on
a monday sorry on a friday saturday
sunday
yeah and you know i'm strongly opposed
to having an authoritarian well
communist dictatorships are a bad thing
even if they do something that you agree
with and um the wicked and despicable
communist dictatorship in china is
i'm glad we don't i'm glad we have a
government that can't do that
and i wouldn't want a government that
could do that but um
but they're not wrong to identify that
this was causing a profound degradation
in in uh
children
and i would i would i would want to go a
long way towards restricting this stuff
and the parents listening there's a good
group
called concord promise
who get parents i think about my godsons
who i'm very close to their father died
and i'm like kind of father figured to
them and um
they're just at the age now where lots
of their friends are getting smartphones
what ages are they're 12. and i and i uh
12 and 11. and
honestly i feel like they're about to be
[ __ ] poisoned you know like it
you know
so i mean i would i personally would
urge parents to whether you want
governments doing that i mean i would be
more uncomfortable with that yeah well
you can have a cultural imposition as
well as a legislative one right you can
make it so that it is
commonly held societal practice that
parents try to restrict the amount of
time that children under the age of
whatever whatever the research seems to
suggest don't let their children i mean
man think about all of the challenges
that me and you have with our attention
and then think about the fact that i
didn't have an iphone
i was part of blackberry squad until
later than it was cool still to be i
didn't have an iphone until probably 24
25 years old so i went through i've been
way way way way more than half my life
you know like two-thirds of my life more
than two-thirds of my life i've had
without a smartphone in my pocket
but yeah it's funny because i remember
when i went to provincetown
and i was off all these devices
i know loads of people my age were
saying to me but what will you do and i
kind of said but you do realize like we
lived half our lives like this yeah yeah
it's not even as if you were 18 years
old and you've grown up never knowing a
world that was out this it's like no no
your life arc had a period of this do
you not remember that you used to do a
thing yeah precisely it was really
interesting and it was even i remember
when i remember when i had to go buy so
i wanted to have a phone that couldn't
get onto the internet i remember even
when i i was in boston because boston's
across the water from providence town
and even i remember going into the shops
and i would say i want a phone that
can't get onto the internet and the guy
in the target could say to me
so this one can only uh the internet's
quite slow and i'm like no no no i
can't access the internet and and he was
just baffled he kept saying what is as
if i wasn't speaking english right it
was just like but what do you mean right
like it was like it was incomprehensible
the concept of not wanting to be on the
internet and um
[Music]
yeah so the the
although i stress that
my goal is not that we not be on the
internet is that we have an internet
that is not designed to maximally invade
or ruin our attention um and essentially
i'm sure
um some people are going to describe my
book as anti-tech
and i am not anti-tech at all the
question is not pro or anti-tech the
question is what tech
working on what principles in whose
interests at the moment we have tech
that's working in the interests of you
know small numbers of people but it
comes back to saying you were saying
before chris i was thinking about as you
were talking
my biggest worry
is
that
this could be like say the obesity
crisis or the climate crisis which is
the furthering you get the harder it is
to get out right it's like when you
become so fat you can't exercise anymore
right my worry is if we don't deal with
it pretty [ __ ] soon if we continue to
degrade or if we continue on the
trajectory where these technologies are
invading us more and more and more
um my worry is will be so far gone our
attention will be so far gone that it's
harder to summon the individual and
collective attention to find our way out
i think we're actually a really
important moment feels like a precipice
man if our capacity to deploy the thing
that makes change gets reduced then the
further in that you get the more
difficult it is to use the thing that
you need to turn it around i i'm dude
i'm so for this you know whatever
you know when you said that i went to
interview um
in copenhagen in denmark i went to
interview this guy called professor suna
layman who did the first study that has
proved that our collective attention
span is shrinking this wasn't that long
into the research for the book
and he said to me
oh i saw i can't do it i can't do the
daily shack said he said i um i saw this
photograph yesterday have you seen it
and he just pulled it up on his phone
and showed it to me
and it was a room
everyone is wearing one of those vr
headsets and mark zuckerberg is the only
person
not wearing the vr headset standing in
front of them i think it became quite a
famous photo after this
and he said having just explained to me
all the ways in which our collective
touches bad was collapsing he said in a
very understated danish way he said
i saw this and i thought
oh [ __ ]
this is the future i'm just like oh [ __ ]
it up
but we're in a race right we're in a
race between all these forces that are
invading our attention and on the other
side there's got to be a movement of all
of ours saying no you [ __ ] don't do i
think when we look back when people look
back in 50 years time probably between
1500 years time they'll look at factory
farming and they'll think hang on you
you bred sentient creatures so that you
could kill them to eat them you you
people were [ __ ] barbaric and they
will say
what the actual [ __ ] were you doing with
your attention what were you doing with
the technology that was supposed to
serve you and you were serving it you
know we don't need terminator we don't
need arnold schwarzenegger to come
around to come down to be a totalitarian
fear-mongering artificial intelligence
robot that's that follows us around we
all have one in our pocket all the time
it's just that it uses slightly more
subtle ways to deploy its techniques
to be clear if arnold schwarzenegger is
watching and would like to come to my
house he's very done he's doing a
[ __ ] mobile game app
advert it's called like titans of tanks
or something and i saw it yesterday and
he's done the get to the chopper but
it's get to the tank instead arnold
you're the governor of california like
you
sure anyway anyway stolen focus while
you can't pay attention johan's new book
will be linked in the show notes below
it's awesome man i think this is this is
the most one of the most important
conversations that people need to have
i'm really really glad that you that you
wrote this book and everybody should go
and check it out oh that christmas has
been such a thoughtful and interesting
conversation i'm going to process loads
of the things you said i'm also meant to
say all my publishers tased me that
anyone who wants to know where to get
the audio book
the ebook or the physical book
can go to stolenfocusbook.com
and i got in trouble at the end of a
podcast about a year ago
because i was i should not have done
this i was interviewed by this guy and
he said um so what's your twitter and i
said it he said what's your facebook and
i said it he said what's your instagram
and i said it and then he said what's
your snapchat and i said
i am a 42 year old man right the only 42
year old men on snapchat are definitely
paedophiles
and he didn't laugh but i have this
terrible thing if i tell a joke if
someone doesn't laugh or i start leaning
into the joke oh no and i said you know
that show to catch a predator the
american show where they basically
catfish pedophiles they pretend to be
children i said the next season of to
catch predator
should be just walking up to adult men
in the street and saying have you guys
what is your snapchat yeah and if they
say this is my handle immediately
[ __ ] throw them in the van i can see
why that would go down badly yeah well
it went out even worse because this guy
didn't laugh at all and i thought oh a
bit po-faced i looked him up later he is
50 years old and has a large snapchat
following so i'm glad we got through
this interview without me accidentally
calling you a pedophile no foot in mouth
no no no snapchat forays no you're fine
uh johan man it's always a pleasure to
speak to you totally my pleasure cheers
chris until the next time mate brilliant
thanks what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace